votre éditeur robert laffont vient de
publier la traduction john le carré de
veau dernier roman la maison russie qui
est un best-seller dans tous les pays où
il est déjà parus notamment aux états
unis où il a déclenché pas mal de
controverses et il est vrai que c'est le
premier roman d'espionnage qui prend en
compte la glace note c'est là après la
pérestroïka alors c'est un roman traduit
de l'anglais par mimi perrin et isabelle
perrin mais nous en parlerons de ce
roman dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission j'irai d'abord que les
français fassent connaissance avec john
le carré est d'abord une chose
évidemment assez étonnante c'est que
votre vrai nom c'est david john moores
cornwell et vous avez choisi comme ceux
de nîmes un nom qui sonne plutôt
français le carré pourquoi alors je vais
vous dire la vérité et puis je vais vous
dire un ensemble
la vérité c'est que j'étais ou temps où
j'ai fait mes débuts d'écrivain jeter
encore dans le fleuve rhône encaissé on
m'a dit c'était l'avis officiel il faut
choisir un nom de plume alors je suis
allé en main à mon éditeur anglais
il a dit alors choisi est choisie c'est
quelque chose de très simple de très
anglo-saxon shanks médecins etc
et puis j'ai choisi john le carré
et la vérité c'est que je ne sais pas
d'où vient ce nom
mais la vérité est toujours tellement
ennuyante que pour les journalistes j'ai
inventé la fiction que j'étais sûr dans
un autobus de londres j'ai j'ai vu un
magasin de chaussures chaussures et il
s'appelait le magasin de john le carré
j'ai volé le nom mais c'est à mon sens
bon alors pourquoi pendant de nombreuses
années
vous avez refusé de dire que vous aviez
été un agent secret et maintenant vous
le volontiers vous le bit enfin en vous
forçant un peu pourquoi avez vous refusé
longtemps de dire la vérité là dessus
j'ai pas refusé de dire la vérité je
l'ait pas mentionné c'est tout mais
c'est la tradition de ces services est
au commencement gt gt très modeste à ce
sujet mais maintenant il ya des livres
des anciens membres des services qui ont
fait mention de moi et et c'est devenu
ridicule rien alors je la voulais depuis
combien d'années voilà à l'égard des
détails je suis encore très modeste